it's also weird because there are a lot
of youtubers who never got off the
ground who I think should have yeah
because if really crippled them like
yeah I don't know should care of me
talking about I'm just gonna [ __ ] do
it that's what I'm so you know like the
the hit-or-miss girl yeah remember like
well that was a thing yeah yeah years
ago when you interviewed yeah yeah yeah
that was a I mean I should pretty
introduce how I actually met her first
let me go into it so before she blew up
isn't hit or miss girl she met me had a
convention because she was a fan and
more my friends after she blew up was
like yo on Instagram she's gonna picture
with you and I'm like what the fine I
don't know this girl and then I went to
an Instagram and sure enough she a
picture with me so i DM de and we were
chatting and I was like yeah if you need
any help with anything cuz normally when
I speak to new youtubers or youtubers
you're blowing up I'm like hey if you
need any help you know with negotiating
a deals you need help dealing with
anything let me know I'll give you
advice I'll help you I'll get you all
sorted it's chill right cuz it's hard I
wish I want to help me yeah yeah yeah so
uh yeah so then I you know she had all
these plans and staff to make content
which I think she should have because
she was in a very rapid where she could
have gotten a career for you know like
at least like 5-10 years yeah the fame
that the level of fame that she had at
that time
oh no like it was insane and it yeah you
around this time you'll know she was
like the thing yeah yeah right it was I
mean my video was garbage and he got a
million views it was a terrible video
yeah surely based off her face and her
name yeah a million views just like that
right not even a problem and there was
compilations of her I've heard doing
anything with hunt with a million plus
views on YouTube right cuz cuz she
didn't upload anything so yeah yeah I
must tell no you know we found a video
for her channel we also tryna get
started but she made a mistake which
which I tell the youtubers
ever ever like what you mean Connor
because you did this is uh don't make a
[ __ ] discord server I think I think I
think being having a discord server that
you're involved in like you're actually
moderating yourself is the quickest way
to get people to start disliking it is
because if you have to ban someone
they'll they'll be like see dog Ben
no using [ __ ] that guy yeah and so she
made a discord server and bare mind you
know she was already like kind of a
target on 4chan yeah then one of the
final information about it so yeah this
became like ice a spit of a discord I
know yeah I know she'll probably say
that it isn't but like I've seen a few
thousand I've been around the Internet I
know a cesspit when I see one I know it
I know a 4chan breeding ground yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they were out for blood
for her like they they like doxxed her
like multiple times they were finding
out where she was they found her
boyfriend yes she hadn't revealed and
they were making it hell for him and her
they were like threatening that they
were gonna come to our house then they
would mention their address and stuff
and like that was a I reckon her chance
of you know having anything was ruined
because she was so preoccupied with all
this [ __ ] and trying to deal with it oh
yeah if people just hating on her
finding your address saying horrible
things about her yeah imma she was a
dude all the time you know like it was
horrible and like III took many times
she would message me like really upset
about it being like what do I do
I don't know what to do man like yeah
you know countless horrible stories I
don't know what I can share what I can't
you so much for sharing it there's just
really horrible things that was
happening to a left right center Center
because she didn't set up the
precautions to deal with this oh no and
she didn't know what she was doing
yeah yeah and but there's even then
there's only so many precautions you can
set up yeah yeah I mean the bigger you
get you normally limit ways that people
can communicate with you right yeah yeah
normally make it very difficult for
people to be on a one-to-one talk with
you yeah also because it's just very
hard to talk to that many people by open
my DMS on Twitter and I was like hey
guys opened yams yeah yeah my DMS would
be pretty much unusable within two days
yeah so and it's just like it's really
tragic cuz she easily could have had a
career
oh no she could have I know she's 40
watching this nothing Wow Connor you
should told me this but it's like how
can I tell you to make a career I did my
best to help ya push if she's not the
one acting on it then he does not my but
she wanted to she wanted to and I don't
know if she really didn't want to know
but there was definitely opportunity
there and I Hannah it was just it was
really sad seeing me like hearing this I
understand how ha
but it can be especially in the
situation she was in because yeah it was
a rare situation that doesn't happen
right yeah it doesn't happen often but
you know when when he gets that point
when it's just you're scared to go
online like like going back to what I
experienced with Sydney I was like I I
had to like just uninstall everything
like I remember I remember I was I took
the phone off of her and I'm like okay
just let me just let me go through the
head comments I'll make sure it's safe
for you and meant going through the
phone for on behalf of her I felt [ __ ]
shitty yeah some some of the things
people can send a [ __ ] horrible
horrible okay especially you especially
back then so I can totally understand
being like dude I just don't want any
involvement in this because if you go
into that thinking that you can make a
career out of this with that kind of
toxic environment I don't know I think
at that point you do yourself more harm
than oh yeah and along and I think there
I mean there is you know there's always
a time when you can make a career online
but I think there is a healthy way to go
about it absolutely and the less healthy
way to go about it I mean I think there
was definitely room for her to do it
yeah it's justice oh no that I think
that was if even if okay I'm not trying
to compare but you know like it's like a
similar situation with the nikohl
all-girl yeah yeah yeah she became a
huge stream and yeah and I think at the
peak of the hit or miss thing it was
bigger than the nico log oh yeah oh yeah
yeah so I I think it was easy but she
just didn't do anything at her parents
were also pretty much like against
anything yeah didn't take any of the
stuff seriously because the thing is if
you want to make a career out of it you
do need like a very good understanding
of the internet yeah which is why how it
operates why I was trying to help her
out yeah yeah like hey and you know that
was also like a ton of like you know
opportunity they stick youtubers coming
out of that with the woodwork to try and
you know get that piece of the pie if
you were right yeah so you would tell me
about all the stuff that some of these
youtubes are saying how it's like oh my
god these some of these dudes a slimy
bro yeah yeah it's just I don't even
Internet's a scary place man it is which
is like I'm so glad I didn't just blow
up
I'm sure though that I got the the slow
climb the slug yeah I got to make every
mistake I got to make all the fuck-ups
like I never
myself before I actually had to learn
all that right so I can deal with it now
which I learned to all but a lot of
people who blow up it's like how the
[ __ ] to you how do you learn how to
negotiate an ad deal
how do you learn how to deal with like a
hundred plus hate comments yeah yeah
have you you know you don't tells you
how to deal with this I don't get much
hate but you know everyone gets a little
bit